I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody. Hi, you guys. Before we get going today, I want to say happy birthday to Mabia Fiff. Thank you, Angela. Yes. As I was arriving today, I saw Angela not open the door for me and instead run past the door. Listen, I did. Because she was up to something. I didn't think you saw me. Although Sam and Cassie, I did say there's a chance she might
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。嗨，你们好。在今天开始之前，我想祝马比亚·菲夫生日快乐。谢谢你，安吉拉。是的。今天我到达时，看到安吉拉没有为我开门，而是跑过了门。听着，我确实跑了。因为她在密谋什么。我以为你没看见我。虽然山姆和卡西，我确实说过她有可能
have seen me. I did say that. Yes, you did. I did that right after I swatted plastic cutlery out of Sam's hand. It was the most aggressive thing I've ever seen you do. No time. No time. No time. She's here. Get the cutlery out of the way. But we love you. We wanted to say happy birthday. Oh, I loved it. I got a giant bouquet of flowers. I mean, humongous, so pretty. And Josh made me some gluten-free treats. He did. Because you get desserts on your birthday at office, ladies. I like it. And then, Angela, you gave me just a beautiful gift. It's an inside joke, I guess we should say. But also, guys, I made the card with my second grade level skill set. And it was an elaborate homemade card, and I loved it. Thank you.
看见我了。我确实说过。是的，你说了。就在我从山姆手中拍掉塑料餐具之后，我就说了。那是我见过你做的最激进的事情。没时间了。没时间了。没时间了。她来了。把餐具拿开。但我们爱你。我们想祝你生日快乐。哦，我太喜欢了。我收到了一大束花。我是说，巨大，太漂亮了。乔什还为我做了一些无麸质的零食。他确实做了。因为在《办公室》女士，你生日那天会有甜点。我喜欢。然后，安吉拉，你给了我一份非常棒的礼物。我想我们应该说这是一个内部笑话。但还有，伙计们，我用我二年级水平的技能制作了这张卡片。这是一张精心制作的自制卡片，我非常喜欢。谢谢。
Thank you. Well, what are we talking about today? We are talking about shareholder meeting, which is Season 6, Episode 11, written by Justin Spitzer and directed by Charles McDougal. Action! Action! Charles McDougal. Here's your summary. Michael heads to a shareholder meeting in New York City, and he brings Andy, Dwight, and Oscar with him. Michael is shocked when he and other higher members of the company are booed while on stage. And he tries to improve the situation by suddenly and publicly making promises that management cannot fill. Meanwhile, back at the office, Jim realizes that nobody takes him seriously as a real boss. That's our summary. Michael, on a stage in front of people, what were you thinking,
谢谢。好吧，我们今天在谈论什么？我们在谈论股东大会，这是第六季第11集，由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，查尔斯·麦克杜格尔执导。开拍！开拍！查尔斯·麦克杜格尔。这是你的剧情摘要。迈克尔前往纽约市参加股东大会，他带上了安迪、德怀特和奥斯卡。当迈克尔和其他公司高层在台上时，他们被嘘声淹没，迈克尔感到震惊。他试图通过突然公开做出管理层无法兑现的承诺来改善局面。与此同时，在办公室里，吉姆意识到没有人把他当作真正的老板。这就是我们的摘要。迈克尔，在人们面前的舞台上，你在想什么，
corporate? What were you thinking? They must have been very desperate, clearly. Fast fact number one. This episode ran on November 19, 2009, during NBC's Green Week. Also known as Green is Universal. Yes. For, you know, NBC Universal. I remember we went to like a party for NBC around this time, and the red carpet was green. Yes. The green carpet. They turned their logo green for this week as well. For Green Week, the net work as shows to incorporate this theme into their episodes somehow. They also ran news stories on environmental issues like hybrid vehicles and hydrofracking. Al Gore made an appearance on 30 Rock. On Community, the college that they attend. Greendale. It's Greendale
公司？你在想什么？他们显然一定非常绝望。第一个速记事实。这一集于2009年11月19日播出，正值NBC的绿色周。也被称为“绿色即通用”。是的。为了，你知道，NBC环球。我记得大约在这个时候我们去参加了一个NBC的派对，红地毯是绿色的。是的。绿色地毯。他们在那一周也将他们的标志变成了绿色。为了绿色周，电视网展示了如何将这个主题以某种方式融入到他们的剧集中。他们还报道了关于混合动力汽车和水力压裂等环境问题的新闻。阿尔·戈尔在《我为喜剧狂》中客串。在《废柴联盟》中，他们就读的大学。格林代尔。是格林代尔
Community College. Well, they changed their name to Environdale. They were already green. I know, but they changed it to Environdale. And then they plan a green concert. This was my favorite tie-in. On Law and Order SVU, they had, quote, an accused killer has to resort to alternate means to make money after too many people have started recycling their own bottles and cans. Wow. Which I thought was, um, it's kind of like too much recycling led to, uh, killing spree. Yeah. Feels like a message, maybe not what Green Week was hoping for. Feels a little forced, guys. No judgment. Feels a little forced. Our contribution to Green Week was recyclups. We have a whole cold open. Oh, rain is recyclups. He really
社区学院。好吧，他们把名字改成了环境代尔。他们本来就是绿色的。我知道，但他们改成了环境代尔。然后他们计划了一场绿色音乐会。这是我最喜欢的联动。在《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》中，他们有，引用，“一名被指控的杀手在太多人开始回收自己的瓶子和罐子后，不得不诉诸其他手段来赚钱。”哇。我觉得这，嗯，有点像过多的回收导致了，呃，杀戮狂潮。是的。感觉像是一个信息，也许不是绿色周所希望的。感觉有点强行，伙计们。没有评判。感觉有点强行。我们对绿色周的贡献是回收怪。我们有一个完整的冷开场。哦，雷恩是回收怪。他真的
got into it. Well, we got a lot info on that. We're gonna break it down for you when we get there. Okay. Fast fact number two is a location breakdown for the shareholder meeting. They were not in New York City. What? Yeah, we didn't fly there and hire all those people in Manhattan. We did not, lady. Where was it? This hotel, all the interiors and the exteriors were shot at the downtown Marriott Hotel on South Figueroa in Los Angeles. Now Marriott sold this property some years back, and it is now called the LA Grand Hotel. We shot at the hotel for three days. On Monday and Tuesday, we were in the main ballroom, and we used 405 background performers each day. And then on Thursday, we were in the
投入其中了。好吧，我们得到了很多关于那个的信息。当我们讲到那里时，我们会为你剖析它。好的。第二个速记事实是股东大会的地点细分。他们不在纽约市。什么？是的，我们没有飞到那里并雇佣曼哈顿的所有那些人。我们没有，女士。那是在哪里？这家酒店，所有的内景和外景都是在洛杉矶南菲格罗亚街的万豪酒店拍摄的。现在万豪几年前卖掉了这个物业，它现在被称为洛杉矶大酒店。我们在酒店拍摄了三天。周一和周二，我们在主宴会厅，我们每天使用了405名背景演员。然后周四，我们在
lobby and the hospitality suite and the kind of drive-up area. The valet. The valet. The drive-up area. Take me to the drive-up area. Hi, could I claim my car from the drive-up area, please? Thank you. I have my thingy for my drive-up area. Well, Randy told us that the hotel provided us with breakfast and craft services for all of our background performers, but Sergio and Alan of Big Time Catering made lunch for everybody. We had to have three serving lines like we did for Company Picnic. It's a lot of people. They went all out. Yeah. All right, let's move on to FastFact number three. I'm very excited about FastFact number three. Me too. Here's the thing about FastFact number three. Tell
大堂、接待套房和那种车道区域。代客泊车。代客泊车。车道区域。带我去车道区域。嗨，我能从车道区域取回我的车吗，谢谢。我有我的车道区域的小东西。好吧，兰迪告诉我们，酒店为我们所有的背景演员提供了早餐和餐饮服务，但大时间餐饮公司的塞尔吉奥和艾伦为每个人做了午餐。我们必须像公司野餐那样设置三条服务线。那是很多人。他们全力以赴。是的。好吧，让我们继续第三个速记事实。我对第三个速记事实非常兴奋。我也是。关于第三个速记事实是这样的。告诉
him. At 15 minutes and 35 seconds, there is a scene with Jim and Ryan back in the Annex. Jim is asking Ryan if he's finished this spreadsheet that he's asked him to do, but Ryan is playing Tetris. This is all part of that Jim Ryan storyline where Ryan is goofing off and no one takes Jim's authority seriously. Seriously, this episode could be called shareholder meeting slash Ryan's ass. It really could. It rolls off the tongue. Well, in the scene of Ryan playing Tetris, I noticed there were a ton of gift bags on Kelly's desk, and I was like, what are all these gift bags about? I just, I had to know what's up with the gift bags. Yeah, I noticed it too. I counted four gift bags. What the heck are these gift
他。在15分35秒时，有一个吉姆和瑞安在附楼的场景。吉姆在问瑞安是否完成了他让他做的电子表格，但瑞安在玩俄罗斯方块。这都是吉姆-瑞安故事情节的一部分，瑞安在偷懒，没有人认真对待吉姆的权威。说真的，这一集可以叫“股东大会”斜杠“瑞安的屁股”。真的可以。朗朗上口。好吧，在瑞安玩俄罗斯方块的场景中，我注意到凯利的桌子上有一堆礼品袋，我就想，这些礼品袋是怎么回事？我只是，我必须知道礼品袋是怎么回事。是的，我也注意到了。我数了四个礼品袋。这些到底是什么鬼
bags about? I was thinking, is there something in the shooting draft? Maybe something that was deleted that could explain this. Well, when I went to check the shooting draft, the entire Jim Ryan storyline, otherwise known as Ryan sass was missing. I mean, it's just not there at all. Completely not there. So I went to the shooting draft because I didn't know Jenna was going to the shooting draft. And then I'm like, Jenna, what the heck? The Ryan sass is gone. And we started trading all these messages about it. You guys, we had a text flurry. We really did. And we decided to get to the bottom of it. Folks, fact number three is going to be a real mom detectives moment. Sam even made us an intro
礼品袋？我在想，拍摄草稿里有什么东西吗？也许有什么被删减的东西可以解释这个。好吧，当我去查看拍摄草稿时，整个吉姆-瑞安故事情节，也就是所谓的“瑞安的屁股”，不见了。我是说，它根本就不在那里。完全不在。所以我去了拍摄草稿，因为我不知道珍娜要去查拍摄草稿。然后我就说，珍娜，这到底是怎么回事？瑞安的屁股不见了。我们开始交换所有关于它的信息。伙计们，我们进行了一场短信轰炸。我们真的进行了。我们决定查个水落石出。各位，第三个事实将是一个真正的“妈妈侦探”时刻。山姆甚至为我们做了一个介绍
for it. It was a cold and rainy night when someone dropped that package through my mailbox. So many clues, so much chaos. It had been a long time since I saw this big of a mess. But because it wasn't a far drive. And because it wasn't a school night. And because there was only a little bit of evidence so I could fit in a small amount of pockets. And because I had snacks in case they got hungry. And because it wasn't chilly out. God helped me. I knew who I needed to call. Mom detectives. I love it so much. It cracks me up. Every piece of that makes me laugh,
它。那是一个寒冷多雨的夜晚，有人把那个包裹扔进了我的邮箱。太多的线索，太多的混乱。距离我看到这么大的烂摊子已经很久了。但因为它开车不远。而且因为那不是上学之夜。而且因为只有一点点证据，所以我可以装进少量的口袋里。而且因为我有零食以防他们饿了。而且因为外面不冷。上帝帮帮我。我知道我需要给谁打电话。妈妈侦探。我太喜欢了。它让我笑个不停。每一部分都让我发笑，
Sam. I love that it starts in a thunderstorm. I love the small amount of evidence that can fit into tiny pockets. And because we have snacks. There were restrooms nearby. Oh, yes. Yes. Well, here it is, folks. I reached out to James Carey and writer Justin Spitzer. And I dug into my digital clutter and I found an email from Randy Cordray. That said, team office. It is looking like we need to shoot some additional material for shareholder meeting. Additional material. What does that mean? I said, Jenna, I found an email. I quickly texted her. Randy goes on to say, we are planning these scenes for Monday, October 19. Webisodes will be moving to Tuesday, October 20. Thank you, Randy Cordray. Well, Jenna, this was
山姆。我喜欢它以雷雨开始。我喜欢可以装进小口袋里的少量证据。而且因为我们有零食。附近有洗手间。哦，是的。是的。好吧，各位，就是这样。我联系了詹姆斯·凯里和编剧贾斯汀·斯皮策。我翻阅了我的数字杂物，发现了一封来自兰迪·科德雷的电子邮件。上面写着，办公室团队。看起来我们需要为股东大会拍摄一些额外的素材。额外的素材。那是什么意思？我说，珍娜，我发现了一封邮件。我立刻给她发了短信。兰迪接着说，我们计划在10月19日周一拍摄这些场景。网络剧集将移至10月20日周二。谢谢你，兰迪·科德雷。好吧，珍娜，这可是
a big deal because we were supposed to go on hiatus. Yes, right. We had this big long hiatus starting October 19, all the way until after the new year. A few of us were going to work on the webisodes, but the majority of the company was officially on hiatus. So Randy was basically saying like, don't go out of town. We might need you. Yes. I found out that Steve was scheduled to shoot the movie dinner for schmucks. So we were shutting down production early that year. I spoke to James Carey, who uncovered the call sheet schedule for shareholder meeting. And it's true. We shot most of this episode the week of September 28, but we did not shoot the Jim Ryan scenes until Friday, October 16.
一件大事，因为我们本该去休假的。是的，没错。我们从10月19日开始有一个很长的假期，一直到新年之后。我们中的一些人要去制作网络剧集，但公司的大多数人正式处于休假状态。所以兰迪基本上是在说，不要出城。我们可能需要你。是的。我发现史蒂夫被安排去拍摄电影《笨人晚宴》。所以那一年我们提前停止了制作。我与詹姆斯·凯里谈过，他发现了股东大会的通告单时间表。这是真的。我们这一集的大部分是在9月28日那一周拍摄的，但我们直到10月16日周五才拍摄吉姆和瑞安的场景。
I had to know why. The plot thickens. Writer Justin Spitzer told me that the Jim Ryan storyline was a part of his original outline for this episode, but it was eventually cut from the shooting draft in favor of staying at the hotel for more scenes of the shareholder meeting. So that plot, that Jim Ryan plot was then shortened and repurposed as a cold open for Scott's tots. What? We actually shot it during Scott's tots, but then it was cut from Scott's tots and it was rewritten again. And we added that shoot day and it went back into shareholder meeting. So Justin said that when they were editing shareholder meeting, they just missed not checking in on the group back at Dunder Mifflin. He also said that in all of these
我必须知道为什么。情节变得复杂了。编剧贾斯汀·斯皮策告诉我，吉姆-瑞安的故事情节是他这一集原始大纲的一部分，但最终为了留在酒店拍摄更多股东大会的场景而从拍摄草稿中删除了。所以那个情节，那个吉姆-瑞安的情节被缩短并重新用作《斯科特的托特》的冷开场。什么？我们实际上是在《斯科特的托特》期间拍摄的，但后来它被从《斯科特的托特》中删除了，并再次重写。我们增加了那个拍摄日，它又回到了股东大会。所以贾斯汀说，当他们剪辑股东大会时，他们只是错过了没有查看邓德·米夫林的那群人。他还说，在所有这些
iterations of the Jim Ryan storyline, the one thing that always happened was that Ryan ended up in a closet. And the reason for this was that they wanted to get BJ out of the background of scenes that were happening in the bullpen. Sneaky. Yes. So that scene that we saw Angela that's in the annex with Ryan playing Tetris. Yeah. That was actually shot during Scott's tots. That is the one scene from that cold open that remained. And then we added all of this other stuff about people not taking Jim seriously and we flushed it out. Well, this was clearly a puzzle, but we haven't figured it out yet. We are still wondering about these four gift bags on Kelly's desk. I was curious which Webisode we were
吉姆-瑞安故事情节的迭代中，唯一发生的事情就是瑞安最终进了壁橱。原因是因为他们想让BJ离开在牛棚里发生的场景背景。鬼鬼祟祟。是的。所以我们在附楼里看到的那个安吉拉，瑞安在玩俄罗斯方块的场景。是的。那实际上是在《斯科特的托特》期间拍摄的。那是那个冷开场中唯一保留下来的场景。然后我们添加了所有关于人们不认真对待吉姆的其他东西，并充实了它。好吧，这显然是一个谜，但我们还没有弄清楚。我们仍然对凯利桌上的这四个礼品袋感到好奇。我很好奇我们那一周在拍摄哪部网络剧集。所以我联系了兰迪，他说那是网络剧集系列中的《导师》。艾琳决定她想学习成为一名会计。我重温了它，这就是它的设置。有时候我在接待处确实感到无聊，我想知道成为一名会计是什么感觉。所以我猜我想说的是，我真的很想要你的生活，但我不知道怎么得到它。你擅长数字吗？计数曾经是我在《芝麻街》中最喜欢的部分。一个苹果，两个苹果，三个苹果。是的。也许它不适合你。我可以做你的导师。好的。你知道，我可以做到。我必须做这里的所有其他事情。所以真的吗？是的。太棒了。哦，嗯哼。整个网络剧集系列是安吉拉·马丁教
shooting that week. So I reached out to Randy and he said it was the mentor in this Web Episode series. Aaron decides she wants to learn to be an accountant. I rewatched it and here's how it's set up. Sometimes I do get bored at reception and I wonder what it's like to be an accountant. So I guess what I'm saying is I really want your life and I don't know how to get it. Are you good with numbers? The count used to be my favorite part of Sesame Street. Van Apple, two apples, three apples. Yeah. Maybe it's not for you. I could be your mentor. Okay. You know, I can do it. I have to do everything else around here. So really? Yes. Great. Oh, uh-huh. This whole Webisode series is Angela Martin teaching
艾琳如何成为一名会计并培养她。进展如何？我们实际上玩得很开心。当然，结果并没有像安吉拉希望的那样，但拍摄起来非常有趣。兰迪还与我分享了通告单。我们在10月19日周一拍摄了网络剧集。那天通告单上有两个有趣的细节。引用，“今天，10月19日，星期一。今天是第二届年度迈克尔·斯科特邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿办公室纪念演职人员趣味万圣节服装大赛，旨在治愈沉闷。”是的。那是因为那一年我们不会在万圣节期间拍摄。我们不得不提前我们的万圣节游行。是的，我们在工作时的服装游行。它还说，引用，“来自NBC.com的视频摄制组
Aaron how to be an accountant and grooming her. How does that go? We actually had so much fun. Of course, it doesn't turn out the way Angela hoped, but it was a blast to shoot. Randy also shared the call sheet with me. We filmed the Webisode on Monday, October 19th. Here were two fun details on the call sheet that day. Quote, Today, Monday, Scare Tober 19th. Today is the second annual Michael Scott Dundermifflin Scranton Office Memorial Cast and Crew Fun Halloween Costume Contest for the Dull Drums Cure. Yes. That's because we were not going to be shooting over Halloween that year. We had to move up our Halloween parade. Yes, our costume parade at work. It also said, Quote, A video crew from NBC.com
今天将在片场。”虽然这解释了我的数字杂物中的另一封邮件，但我发现了一封来自为NBC.com工作的乔亚·巴尔福的邮件，说她要带着一堆摇头娃娃来到片场，让我作为我为NBC制作的《与安吉拉的冒险》片段之一的特色。她甚至与我分享了一张即将上线销售的摇头娃娃的模拟海报。我会把它放在我们的故事里。但这是我好奇的事情。她在邮件结尾说，引用，“明迪有没有为你播放她的新网络剧集歌曲？如果没有，去烦她，因为它太棒了。我整个周末都在哼唱它。”好吧，现在这让我对她说的歌曲感到好奇。所以我查了一下。
will be on set today. While this explained another email from my digital clutter, I had found an email from Joya Balfour who worked for NBC.com saying she was coming to set with a bunch of bobbleheads for me to feature in one of my Adventures with Angela segments for NBC. She even shared with me a mock-up poster for the sale of the bobbleheads that we're going to go online. I'll put that in our stories. But here's the thing I was curious about. She ended her email by saying, Quote, Has Mindy played her new Webisode song track for you? If not, go bug her because it's amazing. I've been humming it all weekend. Well now that got me curious about what song she was talking about. So I looked it up.
在《微妙的性取向》中，网络剧集系列即将在10月29日播出。乔亚已经看到了它的早期剪辑。所以我去重温了它。珍娜，乔亚是对的。这首歌太好听了。听听副歌。我无法把它从脑海中抹去。等等，那是原创歌曲，明迪在唱吗？别说了。那不是很好吗？为什么她不一直去俱乐部表演那个？那太朗朗上口了。这真是一首有趣的歌。这两部网络剧集都太棒了，但它们仍然没有解释礼物。是的。它们在任何删减场景中吗？我在任何删减场景中都没有看到礼品袋。我仍然不知道为什么凯利把它们放在
In subtle sexuality, the Webisode series was about to air on October 29th. And Joya had seen an early edit of it. So I went to re-watch that. Jenna, Joya was right. The song is so good. Just listen to the chorus. I can't get it out of my head. Wait, is that an original song and Mindy is singing it? Stop it. Isn't that so good? Why is she not outperforming that at clubs all the time? That is so catchy. It is really a fun song. And both of those Webisodes were so great, but they still didn't explain the gifs. Yeah. Were they in any of the deleted scenes? I saw no gift bags in any deleted scenes. I still don't know why Kelly has them on
她的桌子上。我甚至读了《斯科特的托特》的拍摄草稿，因为那个场景来自那一集，那一集中没有任何关于凯利和礼品袋的内容。好吧，一些人也注意到了这一点，网上有一个关于它的粉丝理论。U/Stolatron21在Reddit上发布了这个理论。珍娜，这有点道理。好的。U/Stolatron21说，吉姆忘记了凯利的生日第二部分。当迈克尔在纽约参加股东大会时，吉姆作为联合经理被单独留下负责，并让瑞安在壁橱里办公。当吉姆和他说话时，背景中可以看到凯利的桌子上有生日礼物，暗示吉姆又忘记了她的
her desk. I even read the shooting draft for Scott's Tots because the scene came from that episode and there is nothing in that episode about Kelly and gift bags. Well, a few folks also caught this and there is a fan theory online about it. You slash Stolatron21 posted this theory on Reddit. And Jenna, it kind of makes sense. Okay. You Stolatron21 said, Jim forgets Kelly's birthday part two. When Michael is at the shareholder meeting in New York, Jim as co-manager is left solely in charge and makes Ryan his office in the closet. When Jim's talking to him, Kelly's desk is seen in the background with birthday gifts implying Jim forgot her
生日。也许，也许吉姆两次忘记了她的生日？也许。我想那会被提出来。我不知道。听着，伙计们，我们在这里要说的是，虽然我们发现了许多有趣的信息，但我们仍然不确定为什么凯利桌上有礼品袋，我们可能永远不会知道。我们可能永远不会知道。这非常符合“妈妈侦探”的风格。确实有点。我们尝试解决它时玩得很开心。我们一路上有零食、短信和笑声。是的。归根结底是关于旅程。确实是。
birthday again. Maybe, maybe did Jim forget her birthday twice? Maybe. I would think that would be brought up. I don't know. Listen, what we're getting at here, folks, is that while we uncovered a lot of interesting information, we're still not sure why Kelly has gift bags on her desk and we may never know. We may never know. It's very on point for mom detectives. It kind of is. We have a lot of fun trying to solve it. We have snacks and texts and laughs along the way. Yeah. It's ultimately about the journey. It really is.
好吧，伙计们，就是这样。妈妈侦探，我们解决了很多事情，但不是那个问题。不客气。把它放在海报上。我们解决了很多事情，只是不是你问的那个。好吧。我们要休息一下，回来谈谈关于“回收怪”的一切。节目开始时，德怀特打扮成机器人进入，要求每个人在“回收怪”面前鞠躬。是时候回收了，伙计们。这非常夸张。是的。然后吉姆有一个谈话头，他解释说五年前，德怀特开始打扮成这个“回收怪”角色，作为一种，
Well, there you have it, guys. Mom detectives, we solved a lot of things, but not the thing in question. You're welcome. Put that on the poster. We solved a lot of things, just not what you asked. All right. We're going to take a break and we'll be back to talk all things recyclops. The show starts with Dwight entering dressed as a robot and demands everyone bow down before recyclops. It's time to recycle, guys. It's very over the top. Yes. And then Jim has a talking head where he explains that five years ago, Dwight started dressing up as this recyclops character as a way to,
我想，公司有这个强制性的回收计划，这是德怀特对此的回应。是的。我想这就是他打算如何激励人们在吉姆谈话头期间进行回收的方式。我注意到了什么。那是什么？我又要说一些火车的事情了。天哪。什么？我知道。你们在重温时有没有注意到，吉姆办公室里吉姆身后的火车海报不见了？没有。火车爱好者吉姆把他的火车海报拿下来了？正是。为什么？为什么一个像吉姆·哈珀特那样热爱火车的人会把这张海报拿下来，安吉拉？我不知道，但我确实发现了一些关于火车海报的事情。
I guess, corporate had this mandated recycling program and this is Dwight's answer to that. Yeah. I guess that's how he's going to help motivate people to recycle during this Jim talking head. I noticed something. What is that? Here I go with some train stuff. Oh my gosh. What? I know. Did you notice, you guys, when you rewatched that the train poster behind Jim in his office is gone? No. Train enthusiast Jim has taken his train poster down? Exactly. Why? Why would someone who loves trains as much as Jim Halpert take this poster down, Angela? I don't know, but I did find out something about the train poster.
那甚至不在那里？那甚至不在那里。你谷歌了那张不见的海报？我没有谷歌它。好吧，谷歌才出现没多久，所以你是怎么研究它的，安吉拉？你知道吗？你知道吗？坐下，女士。你坐下。珍娜，我不是唯一一个对火车感到兴奋的人。经营《办公室》女士Facebook粉丝页面的尼基与我分享说，Facebook群组的一名成员发布了关于吉姆火车海报的信息，她认为我应该知道。好吧，告诉我们。这是对埃里克·斯莱科瓦克的致敬。他是斯克兰顿地区附近铁路的一名真正的火车工程师。他写道，吉姆办公室里的海报实际上是“菲比·斯诺”的画。
That's not even there? That's not even there. You Googled the poster that is gone? I didn't Google it. Well, Google's only been around for a little while, so how did you research it, Angela? You know what? You know what? Sit down, lady. You sit it down. I'm not the only one who is excited about trains, Jenna. Nicky, who runs the Office Ladies Facebook fan page, shared with me that a member of the Facebook group posted information about Jim's train poster and she thought I should know. Well, tell us. This is a shout out to Eric Slekovac. He is an actual locomotive engineer for a railroad that is around the Scranton area. He wrote that the poster in Jim's office is actually a painting of the Phoebe Snow.
这是一列由伊利拉卡瓦纳铁路运营的著名客运列车。它服务于斯克兰顿，那幅画描绘了“菲比·斯诺”在斯克兰顿停靠。斯克兰顿车站仍然屹立不倒，现在是一家美丽的酒店，叫雷迪森，在整个系列中都有提到。埃里克接着说，我希望你们都喜欢另一次火车书呆子之旅。埃里克，我喜欢。非常感谢你的分享。嘴巴张大了？是的。我喜欢埃里克的资料。对吧？我对我们的布景装饰团队印象深刻，他们在吉姆的办公室里放了一幅如此美妙具体的画，现在不见了。我们不知道为什么。我们不知道为什么。我想谁会去追踪它？妈妈侦探？妈妈侦探。所以我们永远不会
It was a famous passenger train run by the Erie La Coana Railroad. It serves Scranton and that painting depicts the Phoebe Snow stopping at Scranton. The Scranton station is still standing and is now a beautiful hotel called the Radisson, which is mentioned throughout the series. Eric goes on to say, I hope you all enjoyed another train nerd out. And Eric, I did. Thank you so much for sharing. Mouth agape? Yeah. I loved Eric's info. Right? And I am so impressed by our set dressing team that they put such a wonderfully specific painting in Jim's office, which is now gone. We don't know why. We don't know why. I guess who's going to be tracking it? Mom detective? Mom detective. So we'll never
查个水落石出。我们永远不会查个水落石出，但我们会寻找它。把它写在卡片上。菲比·斯诺在哪里？是的。菲比·斯诺在哪里？菲比·斯诺在哪里？那简直是一个剧集标题。我知道。好的。回到这一集。我真的很喜欢那个。埃里克，谢谢。我知道。尼基，谢谢你告诉我们。我们要开始一系列的回忆。我们将看到“回收怪”在五年内进化。这真的很有趣，因为我们第一次看到“回收怪”时，他在接待处，我们不得不回到我们旧的发型和旧的衣橱。他们把我的头发弄皱了，他们遇到了困难。他们不得不像真的那样让约翰的头发变得像
get to the bottom of it. We'll never get to the bottom of it, but we're going to look for it. Put this on a card. Where is the Phoebe Snow? Yeah. Where is the Phoebe Snow? Where is the Phoebe Snow? That's literally an episode title. I know. Okay. Back to this episode. I really loved that. Eric, thank you. I know. And Nikki, thanks for letting us know. We're going to start a series of flashbacks. We are going to see recyclops evolve over five years. This was really fun because the first time we see recyclops, he's up at reception and we got to go back to our old hairstyles and our old wardrobe. They scrunched up my hair and they had a hard time. They had to like really like make John's hair go like
那样蓬松的拖把头。对吧？这真的很可爱。然后我不知道你有没有注意到，接下来，瑞安在接待处。记得瑞安介入的时候吗？哦，是的。所有这些回忆中最有趣的是看到多年来所有不同的接待员迭代。好吧，第二年当“回收怪”真正开始成形时，罗尼在接待处。记得吗，她是由戴尔·劳尔扮演的。但唯一的问题是，这个“回收怪”活动应该是二月份地球日的年度活动。而罗尼实际上是帕姆在艺术学校时夏天的接待员。哦，身体妈妈侦探，把那个香菇都弄出来了。是的，非常感谢。不客气。
all in that like floppy mop do. Right? It was really cute. And then I don't know if you noticed, but next up, Ryan is at reception. Remember when Ryan stepped in? Oh yeah. What was so fun about all these flashbacks is seeing all the different like iterations of receptionists over the years. Well, the next year when recyclops has really started to take shape, Ronnie is at reception. Remember, she was played by Dale Raul. But the only problem with this is that this recyclops event is supposed to be an annual event in February for Earth Day. And Ronnie was actually the receptionist over the summer when Pam was at art school. Oh, body mom detective, the shiitake out of that one. Yeah, thank you very much. You're welcome.
然后“回收怪”，你知道，最终进入了这个最后阶段，非常精致。但看起来他现在像变成了终结者。是的，他现在实际上用气溶胶喷雾破坏东西。斯坦利有这段很棒的对话，他说，等等，我以为你被污染独角兽杀死了，德怀特说，污染独角兽想得美。我知道。雷恩喜欢打扮成那种终结者的样子。我给他拍了一张照片。珍娜，它在我们的书里。我知道。他就像个孩子。他就像个孩子一样玩装扮游戏。我联系了我们的服装设计师艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫特，问她关于“回收怪”这个惊人转变的一切。你知道，我们之前说过，艾丽西亚特别擅长用很少的钱从零开始制作服装。虽然她说对于这个，她有相当不错的预算。但我发现她在剧院工作过。这就是为什么她如此擅长制作这些服装。她为蓝人组合工作，她在百老汇的《狮子王》中做木偶维护。天哪。是的。为了开始这个，她告诉我她会拍一张雷恩的照片，然后她会像在上面画一个覆盖层。这样她就能真正看到雷恩在所有这些不同的服装中会是什么样子。我觉得这很神奇。这很神奇。艾丽西亚是一位伟大的艺术家。是的。她甚至与我们分享了她的草图。我们有它们，她所有的“回收怪”草图。第一
Then recyclops, you know, ends up in this final stage, very elaborate. But it seems like he's now like turned to like a terminator. Yeah, he's now actually destroying things with aerosol spray. And Stanley has this great dialogue where he's like, wait, I thought you were killed by Polluticorn and Dwight's like Polluticorn wishes. I know. Rain loved dressing up in that like terminator outfit. I took a picture of him. Jenna, it's on our book. I know. He was like a kid. He was like a kid getting to play dress up. I connected with our costume designer, Alicia Raycraft, to ask her all about this amazing transformation of recyclops. You know, we've said before that Alicia was particularly gifted at building
件事她会做的是把她的草图展示给编剧。在这种情况下，他们确实在某些情况下剖析了“回收怪”应该是什么样子。例如，对于第一个“回收怪”，剧本中写道，2005年地球日，德怀特穿着一件“思考绿色”T恤，嘴上戴着头巾，额头上有一只第三只眼，同时向每个人讲授回收利用。所以艾丽西亚告诉我，她的第一个担忧是那个描述让她有点想起《我为喜剧狂》中一个叫“绿色动物园”的角色，由大卫·休默扮演。绿色动物园是《我为喜剧狂》的“回收怪”？是的，有点。他是这个环保活动家。他穿得像一件绿色衬衫。他戴着绿色棒球帽。所以当她在勾勒
costumes from scratch for very little money. Although she said for this, she had a pretty good budget. But I found out she worked in the theater. And this is why she was so talented at building these costumes. She worked for Blue Man Group, and she did the puppet maintenance on the Lion King on Broadway. Oh my gosh. Yeah. To get started on this, she told me that she would take a picture of rain and then she would sketch like an overlay on top of it. So she could really see what rain would look like in all these different costumes. I found that sort of amazing. It is amazing. And Alicia is a great artist. Yes. She even shared her sketches with us. We have them, all of her sketches of recyclops. The first
德怀特的第一个服装时，她想确保没有人会认为这是绿色动物园。然后剧本写道，2006年地球日，德怀特穿着一件“爱地球”T恤，披风，护腕，护肘，护膝，月球靴，全摩托车头盔，额头中间有一只更大的眼睛，同时向办公室里的每个人讲课。在艾丽西亚的笔记中，她写了这一点，我觉得很搞笑。她写道，引用，“我不认为这对德怀特来说还有什么关于地球日的事情。”所以就像，她说服装需要反映这一点。但后来剧本变得非常模糊。接下来的两个，2006年9月和2007年2月，他们只是说德怀特穿着一套更严肃的服装
thing she would do is show her sketches to the writer. And in this case, they really did break down in some cases, what recyclops should look like. So for example, for the very first recyclops, in the script, it said, Earth Day 2005, Dwight is wearing a think green T-shirt, a bandana over his mouth and a third eye on his forehead while lecturing everyone on recycling. So Alicia told me that her first concern was that that description reminded her a little bit of this character called Green Zoo from 30 Rock, who was played by David Schwimmer. Green Zoo was 30 Rocks. Recyclops? Yeah, kind of. He was this environmental activist. He wore like a green shirt. He wore a green baseball cap. So when she was sketching
或者服装更精致。所以她真的不得不开始编造东西。她真的编了。但现在的“回收怪”是这样写的。他穿着厚重的绿色防弹衣，这使得走路很困难。他胸前有一个闪烁的LED显示屏。他手上贴着气溶胶罐，喷出红色的雾气。武器带上装着中国星、回旋镖、武士刀、击剑剑。他头上戴着一个中间有洞的头盔，露出他那只巨大的眼睛。所以对于这个，艾丽西亚说她研究了滑板和曲棍球装备以及长曲棍球装备，因为她想让整个东西有一种像潜行行动的感觉。她说他们收集了一切，她不想
out Dwight's first costume, she wanted to make sure no one was going to think this was Green Zoo. So then the script said, Earth Day 2006, Dwight is wearing a Love Earth T-shirt, a cape, wrist guards, elbow pads, knee pads, moon boots, a full motorcycle helmet, and a larger eye in the middle of his forehead as he lectures everyone in the office. And in Alicia's notes, she wrote this, which I found hilarious. She wrote, quote, I don't think this has anything to do with Earth Day anymore for Dwight. So like, she's like the costume needs to reflect that. But then the script got really vague. The next two for September 2006 and February 2007, they just say Dwight isn't a much more serious costume
强迫雷恩试穿所有这些装备。所以艾丽西亚自己穿上了。她给我发了一张她自己的照片。天哪。他们把这套服装建在艾丽西亚身上。然后一旦他们得到批准，他们就把它穿在雷恩身上。她还说，关于LED盒子应该写什么，有很多来回的讨论。然后他们最终决定写“杀”。这就是“回收怪”如何进化并最终形成的。谢谢你，艾丽西亚，翻阅你所有的数字杂物并给我们发送那些惊人的草图。我们会把它们发布在播客故事里。是的，它们太美了。就像你真的看到她不仅是一位惊人的草图艺术家，而且还是这个，天哪，她会缝纫、画草图，什么都能做。我确实注意到了
or the costume is more elaborate. And so she just really had to start making things up. She really did. But the present day recyclops was scripted like this. He wears heavy green body armor, which makes it difficult to walk. There is a blinking LED display on his chest. He has aerosol cans taped to his hands, which spray a red mist. A weapon belt holds Chinese stars, boomerang, samurai sword, fencing epi. On his head, he wears a helmet with a hole in the middle showing his one giant eye. So for this, Alicia said she researched skateboarding and hockey equipment as well as lacrosse equipment because she wanted the whole thing to have sort of like a subterfuge ops sort of feel. She said they gathered everything and she didn't want to
珍娜，在这一集的第一个拍摄草稿中。这就是关于整个冷开场的内容，第一个拍摄草稿。冷开场即将到来，分号，回收怪，五个感叹号，冷开场结束。这就是它说的全部。是的，你知道，当我和贾斯汀谈论吉姆-瑞安故事情节时，他说这一集真的是拼凑起来的。回收怪是后来才加进去的。我们确实在拍摄这一集时拍摄了回收怪。但是的，这一集是，你知道，零零碎碎，零零碎碎。好吧，在我们结束冷开场之前，我只是有一个非常随机的想法。是什么？如果明迪收到了四份礼物，把它们放在她的桌子上，然后把它们忘在那里了呢？然后他们拍摄了俄罗斯方块场景，没有人注意到它们。
force rain to like try on all this equipment. So Alicia put it on herself. And she sent me a picture of herself. Oh my gosh. And they built this costume onto Alicia. And then once they got it approved, they put it onto rain. And she also said there was like a lot of back and forth about what the LED box should say. And then they finally settled on kill. And that is how recyclops evolved and ultimately came to be. And thank you, Alicia, for digging through all of your digital clutter and sending us those amazing sketches. We're going to post them in pod stories. Yes, they're so beautiful. Like you really see what a just amazing sketch artist she is as well as being this, you know, my gosh, she can sew and sketch and do everything. I did notice
它们实际上是给明迪的礼物，而不是凯利·卡普尔。只是提出来。天哪，我是说，我们没有核实的一个人是明迪。我知道。我们应该给她发一张截图，说，明迪，有什么特别的事情发生吗？我只是说，如果那是明迪的特别日子，人们给了她礼物，她把它们留在桌子上，跑去拿零食，然后他们拍摄了俄罗斯方块场景。我不知道。我不买那个理论，因为维达不可能无缘无故地允许礼品袋在明迪的桌子上。她会说，礼品袋是怎么回事？不，你是对的。你是对的。好的。好吧，再一次，我们可能永远不会知道。但我们学到了很多其他事情。我们永远不会停止好奇。这是我们给你的礼物。
Jenna in the very first shooting draft for this episode. This is what it said about this whole cold open, very first shooting draft. Cold open to come, semicolon, recyclops, five exclamation points, end of cold open. That's all it said. Yeah, you know, when I was talking to Justin about the Jim Ryan storyline, he said this episode really came in pieces. That recyclops was added a little later. We did ultimately shoot reexcyclops while shooting this episode. But yeah, this one was, you know, bits and pieces, bits and pieces. Well, before we end the cold open, I just had a really random thought. What is it? What if Mindy was given four gifts and set them on her desk and forgot them there? And then they shot the Tetris scene and no one noticed them.
一种惊奇和好奇的感觉。好吧。好吧，听着，这一集将以迈克尔开始。他在练习挥手和点头。他应该站着吗？他应该坐下吗？是的。他应该旋转吗？哦，不。不要旋转。不要旋转。他试图弄清楚当他们在股东大会上宣布他的名字，当他在舞台上时，他要做什么。每个人真的只是想让他挥挥手。是的。菲利斯对旋转的反应是我最喜欢的。是的，相当不错。这就像一件事。显然，这个旋转有历史。这不是他第一次提出来。我觉得从一开始，我想我有第一句台词，帕姆说，是的，那太棒了。那太棒了。挥手。
And they were actually gifts for Mindy, not Kelly Kapoor. Just throwing it out there. My god, I mean, the one person we didn't check with was Mindy. I know. We should send her a screenshot of it and be like, Mindy, was there something special happening? I'm just saying, what if it was a special day for Mindy and people had given her gifts and she left them on her desk and ran to get a snack and then they shot the Tetris scene. I don't know. I don't buy that theory because there is no way that VEDA would allow gift bags on Mindy's desk for no reason. She'd be like, what's up with the gift bags? No, you're right. You're right. Okay. Well, again, we may never know. But we learned a lot of other things. We will never stop wondering. It's our gift to you.
我觉得那是因为这是他向我们展示的第15件事。哦，是的。不过，事情是这样的。当迈克尔练习挥手时，奥斯卡正在他的电脑上查找邓德·米夫林的股票价格，情况不太好。他希望迈克尔认真对待。好吧，在迈克尔和奥斯卡在奥斯卡桌子前的这个场景中，我有两个背景捕捉。在3分28秒，请注意屏幕上极好的DMI股票页面。你知道，那是奥斯卡正在看的那个。那是我们的图形设计师亨利·塞恩创建的，兰迪与我们分享了它的原件。我会把它放在我们的故事里。第二个背景捕捉。我称之为纸牌捕捉。是梅雷迪思吗？3分
A sense of wonder and curiosity. All right. Well, listen, this episode is going to start with Michael. He's practicing waving and nodding. Should he stand? Should he sit down? Yeah. Should he twirl? Oh, no. Don't twirl. Do not twirl. He's trying to figure out what he's going to do when they announce his name at the shareholder meeting, when he's up on the stage. Everyone really just wants him to give a little wave. Yeah. Phyllis' reaction to the twirl is my favorite. Yeah, it's pretty good. It's like a thing. Clearly, there's history with this twirl. It's not the first time he's brought it up. I feel like from the very beginning, I think I have the first line and Pam's like, yeah, that's great. That's great. Do the wave.
32秒。凯特在整个场景中都在她的电脑上玩纸牌。你可以看到她的游戏。是的。她总是做得很好。她非常擅长。好吧，艾琳要宣布迈克尔的豪华轿车到了。他的豪华轿车。不，不，不。那是城镇轿车。她说，我很确定那是豪华轿车。每个人都去看外面。确实是。他们派了一辆加长豪华轿车。每个人都超级印象深刻。但奥斯卡，他再次说，这是经典的邓德·米夫林。他们没有钱，他们只是像那样把它扔出来。这当然，珍娜引导我到了bigcars.com。哦，bigcars.com？是的，它确实。它听起来，我不知道它听起来像什么。我知道。我知道。它听起来像是我搜索历史中随机的东西，但它就在那里，因为在1889年，
I feel like that's because this is like the 15th thing he showed us. Oh, yeah. Here's the thing, though. While Michael is practicing waving, Oscar is looking up on his computer the stock prices for Dunder Mifflin, and it's not good. He would like Michael to take it seriously. Well, I have two background catches during this scene between Michael and Oscar at Oscar's desk. At three minutes, 28 seconds, please note the superb on-screen DMI stock page. You know, it's the one Oscar's looking at. That was created by our graphic designer, Henry Sane, and Randy shared with us the original of it. I'll put it in our stories. Second background catch. I'm calling it a solitaire catch. Is it Meredith? Three minutes,
第一辆豪华轿车被引入法国巴黎。真的吗？是的。我必须知道更多。豪华轿车是从哪里来的，珍娜？我必须知道。豪华轿车这个词实际上来自法语单词。我不会说得对。Limousine。等等，等等。豪华轿车这个词来自法语单词limousine。我很震惊。我们是怎么想出那个的？听着，有一件事我想和你分享。它相对较新。就像在过去六个月里，它叫谷歌翻译。谷歌刚刚想出了它。他们确实想出了。它是全新的。哦，就像在过去几天里？是的。它字面上，它是全新的。如果你在你的应用程序上查找它，它是，好的，一秒钟。我们正在输入limousine。谷歌又是什么？它是一个大约在五年前出现的搜索引擎
32 seconds. Kate is playing solitaire on her computer through the whole scene. You can see her game. Yeah. She always did very well. She was very good at it. Well, Erin is going to announce that Michael's limo has arrived. His limo. No, no, no. It's a town car. She's like, I'm pretty sure it's a limo. Everyone goes and looks outside. It sure is. They sent a stretch limo. Everyone is super impressed. But Oscar, who once again is like, this is classic Dunder Mifflin. They don't have the money and they're just throwing it out there like that. This, of course, Jenna led me to bigcars.com. Oh, bigcars.com? Yeah, it did. It sounds, I don't know what it sounds like. I know. I know. It sounds like a random thing to have in my search history, but there it is because in 1889, the
我以后需要你教我怎么用那个。好吧。根据谷歌翻译，这就是法语中豪华轿车的意思。Limousine。等等，等等。这就是它说的。这就是它说的。哦，等等。哦，等等。也许。哦，我播放了英语。好的，等等。这就是你在法语中做的方式。Limousine。哦，limousine。我希望这是一个重复的片段，你用英语播放它，然后说，哦，听起来很相似。哦，天哪。天哪，天哪，天哪。好的。好的，大家。Limousine。好吧，我必须知道第一辆豪华轿车起源于哪里。它是法国的一个前省份，最初的豪华轿车有一个封闭的乘客舱，司机暴露在自然环境中。据说汽车的封闭部分类似于乡村牧羊人穿的豪华轿车斗篷。所以牧羊人
first limousine automobile was introduced to Paris, France. Really? Yes. I had to know more. Where did the limousine come from, Jenna? I had to know. The word limousine actually comes from the French word. I'm not going to say it right. Limousine. Wait, wait. The word limousine comes from the French word limousine. I'm shocked. How did we come up with that? Listen, there is a thing that I want to share with you. It's relatively new. Like in the last six months, it's called Google Translate. Google just came up with it. They did. It's brand new. Oh, just like in the last few days? Yeah. It's literally, it's brand new. If you look it up on your app, it's, okay, one second. We're typing in limousine. What is Google again? It's a search engine that came about about five
在法国一个叫limousine的省份穿的斗篷是该地区人们穿着方式的特定服装，因为他们在寒冷中在外面耕作和放牧，他们会用一种像马车一样的车运输他们的货物，其中一部分被覆盖，司机暴露在外。好的。好吧。那就是“豪华轿车”这个词诞生的时候，它指的是一种有司机的交通工具。历史上，豪华轿车是运送车辆。是的。直到伍德罗·威尔逊乘坐一辆有司机的汽车，豪华轿车才被用来运送人，重要人物。哇。那有点变成了那回事。豪华轿车显示了乘客和司机之间的分离。然后一旦有司机的交通工具开始与富人联系在一起，
years ago. I'll need you to show me how to use that later. All right. This is how you say limousine in French, according to Google Translate. Limousine. Wait, wait. That's what it says. That's what it says. Oh, wait. Oh, wait. Maybe. Oh, I played the English. Okay, wait. This is how you do it in French. Limousine. Oh, limousine. I hope this is a reoccurring segment where you play it in English and go, oh, it sounds similar. Oh, lord. Lordy, lordy, lordy. Okay. Okay, everybody. Limousine. All right. Well, I had to know where the first limousine originated. It was a former province in France and the original limousine had a closed passenger compartment and the driver was exposed to the elements. The enclosed portion of the car was said to resemble the limousine cloaks that were worn by the countryside shepherds. So the shepherds
几年前。我待会儿得让你教我怎么用那个。好吧。根据谷歌翻译，法语里豪华轿车是这么说的。Limousine。等等，等等。它就是这么说的。它就是这么说的。哦，等等。哦，等等。也许吧。哦，我刚才播放的是英语。好吧，等等。法语里是这么说的。Limousine。哦，Limousine。我希望这是一个常设环节，你播放英语，然后说，哦，听起来很像。哦，天哪。天哪，天哪，天哪。好吧。好吧，各位。Limousine。好吧，我得知道第一辆豪华轿车起源于哪里。它曾是法国的一个省，最初的豪华轿车有一个封闭的乘客舱，而司机则暴露在风雨中。据说汽车的封闭部分类似于乡村牧羊人穿的利穆赞斗篷。所以牧羊人
in a province of France called limousine were cloaks that were specific to that region of how people dressed because they were outside farming and shepherds in the cold and they would transport their goods in a type of like horse-drawn cart with part of it covered in the driver exposed. Okay. All right. That is when the word limousine, which referred to a chaufford type of transportation, was born. Historically, limos were delivery vehicles. Yeah. And it wasn't until Woodrow Wilson rode in a chaufford car that the limousine was used to transport people, important persons. Wow. And that sort of became the thing. A limousine showed the separation between passenger and driver. And then once chaufford transportation started being associated with the wealthy,
在法国一个叫利穆赞的省份，穿着该地区特有的斗篷，因为他们要在寒冷的环境中务农和放牧，他们会用一种马车运输货物，马车的一部分有遮盖，而司机则暴露在外。好吧。好吧。这就是“limousine”这个词的由来，它指的是一种有司机的交通工具。从历史上看，豪华轿车是运输车辆。是的。直到伍德罗·威尔逊乘坐了一辆有司机的汽车，豪华轿车才开始被用来运送重要人物。哇。这后来就成了惯例。豪华轿车显示了乘客和司机之间的隔断。然后，一旦有司机的交通工具开始与富人联系在一起，
well, then it was the bigger, the more flashier, the better, right? Okay. The stretch limousine, for example, is an American-made limousine and that's like the one you would take to prom or parties and everyone would pile in. According to coldwire.com, here are the list of type of limos you can get now. Oh, okay. Standard stretch limo, sedan limo, Hummer limo, SUV limo, a limo bus, eco-friendly limo, convertible limo, tank limo, jacuzzi limo, and an old-fashioned limo. Oh. Is that a limo where I drink an old-fashioned? It should be. There you have it, guys. Limousine originated in limousine. Here's what I'm getting from that. In order to qualify to be a limousine versus, let's say, just a chaufford town car, there must be a separation between passenger and driver.
嗯，那时候就是越浮夸越好，对吧？好的。比如加长豪华轿车，那是美国制造的豪华轿车，就像那种你会坐着去参加舞会或派对的车，大家都会挤进去。根据coldwire.com的说法，这是你现在能买到的豪华轿车类型。哦，好的。标准加长豪华轿车、轿车式豪华轿车、悍马豪华轿车、SUV豪华轿车、豪华巴士、环保型豪华轿车、敞篷豪华轿车、坦克豪华轿车、按摩浴缸豪华轿车，还有老式豪华轿车。哦。那是那种我可以在里面喝“古典鸡尾酒”（Old-fashioned）的豪华轿车吗？应该是吧。好了，伙计们，这就是豪华轿车。我从中得到的信息是：要成为一辆豪华轿车，而不是仅仅是一辆有司机的城镇轿车，乘客和司机之间必须有隔断。
That is correct. And so that would be like the little window. Or in some other types of older limousines, the driver is actually outside of the enclosed car. Like you sort of see those, I think, sometimes like Buckingham Palace has an oldie, they'll pull out every once in a while. Right. That would be a limousine. Yeah. Fascinating. Oh, there you have it. I like learning things like this. You know, it makes me an interesting dinner companion, I think. You got lots of stuff. You can just throw out at a random cocktail gathering. I really do. It's one of the benefits of doing this podcast. I love tidbits.
没错。所以那就像是一个小窗户。或者在某些其他类型的老式豪华轿车中，司机实际上是在封闭车厢外面的。就像你有时会看到的那样，我想，白金汉宫偶尔会开出一辆老式车。对。那才叫豪华轿车。是的。太迷人了。哦，就是这样。我喜欢学习这样的知识。你知道，我觉得这让我成为一个有趣的晚餐伴侣。你有很多东西可以在随意的鸡尾酒会上抛出来。我确实有。这是做这个播客的好处之一。我喜欢这些小知识。
We do love a tidbit. This limo seats eight people. Michael wants to bring the whole gang, but we're going to have to decide who actually gets to go to the shareholder meeting. I absolutely loved our limo driver. He was so good. Randy told me that he was played by our very own transportation captain, Mike Stork. He was so no-nonsense. I guess when it was time to cast the role, Randy talked to Allison about maybe using one of our transportation regulars because this person was going to have to actually navigate a stretch limo through Los Angeles traffic while we were rolling. So, Randy was like, it'd be great if we could have an actor with professional driving experience.
我们确实喜欢小知识。这辆豪华轿车可以坐八个人。迈克尔想带上整个团队，但我们得决定谁能真正去参加股东大会。我非常喜欢我们的豪华轿车司机。他太棒了。兰迪告诉我，他是由我们的交通队长迈克·斯托克扮演的。他真是太务实了。我想当需要选角时，兰迪和艾莉森商量过，也许可以用我们的一位交通部门常客，因为这个人必须在我们要拍摄时，真正驾驶一辆加长豪华轿车穿过洛杉矶的交通。所以，兰迪觉得，如果我们能有一位有专业驾驶经验的演员就太好了。
Well, I guess Justin Spitzer and Paul Lieberstein did a little mini-audition with Mike, and they loved his dry delivery. It was so perfect. It was so perfect. So, here's who ends up going to the shareholder meeting, Andy, Michael, Dwight, and Oscar. And they are living it up in the limo. They are so excited. There's drinks, and Michael says it's bigger than where he sleeps. Is he still sleeping on the bench? Is he still sitting on the bench, even though Jan's gone? I don't know.
嗯，我想贾斯汀·斯皮策和保罗·利伯斯坦和迈克进行了一次小试镜，他们很喜欢他那种冷幽默的表达方式。太完美了。太完美了。所以，最终去参加股东大会的人是安迪、迈克尔、德怀特和奥斯卡。他们在豪华轿车里玩得很开心。他们非常兴奋。有饮料，迈克尔说这比他睡觉的地方还大。他还在睡长椅吗？即使简走了，他还在睡长椅吗？我不知道。
That's what I thought, too. I found out a little bit about how we shot these limousine scenes from our own Randy Cordray. At six minutes, 12 seconds, we see inside the limo. It's really driving down the road. Randy said this was shot with Charles McDougal, our director, sitting in the front seat, and Matt Sohn inside of the back of the limo with the cast. He said, we drove the limo around Belboa Park, which is a very good palm tree-free zone. Now, then at six minutes, 38 seconds, we see the limo driving down the streets of Los Angeles, substituting for New York City.
我也这么想。我从我们的兰迪·科德雷那里了解了一些关于我们如何拍摄这些豪华轿车场景的情况。在6分12秒，我们看到了豪华轿车内部。它确实是在路上行驶。兰迪说这是由我们的导演查尔斯·麦克杜格尔坐在前座，马特·索恩在豪华轿车后座和演员们一起拍摄的。他说，我们开着豪华轿车绕着巴尔博亚公园转，那是一个非常好的没有棕榈树的区域。然后，在6分38秒，我们看到豪华轿车行驶在洛杉矶的街道上，代替纽约市。
And he said, for this, we shot car to car. Matt Sohn was in one car, hanging out the window, filming our limo from across traffic. And he said, for this scene, we rented four New York City-looking taxi cabs to be around the limo to help sell the idea that they were in New York. It was a nice touch, I noticed that. Yeah. Well, the fellows are going to arrive at the fancy building that the shareholder meeting is in. Did you see the people protesting in the lobby? Wait.
他说，为了这个，我们进行了车对车拍摄。马特·索恩在另一辆车里，探出窗外，从车流对面拍摄我们的豪华轿车。他说，为了这个场景，我们租了四辆看起来像纽约市的出租车，围在豪华轿车周围，以帮助营造他们身处纽约的感觉。这是一个很好的细节，我注意到了。是的。嗯，伙计们要到达股东大会所在的豪华大楼了。你看到大厅里抗议的人了吗？等等。
Right as they walk through, there's a whole bunch of people protesting the Dunder Mifflin shareholder meeting. At six minutes, 53 seconds, you can see them, they're all holding up signs. My favorite was Blunder Mifflin. I love it. I thought that was a great job by Phil Shea. And yeah, if they were paying attention, they'd notice right away, this is not going to be smooth sailing.
就在他们走过去的时候，有一大群人在抗议邓德·米夫林的股东大会。在6分53秒，你可以看到他们，他们都举着牌子。我最喜欢的是“Blunder Mifflin”（笨蛋米夫林）。我喜欢。我觉得菲尔·谢做得很好。是的，如果他们注意的话，他们会立刻发现，这不会是一帆风顺的。
Well, they don't notice. They are greeted by Lori, who's going to take Michael up to the lounge. Lori was played by Amy Kale Peterson. And when Michael gets to the lounge, he is introduced finally to Alan Brand. Yeah. We're going to meet this Alan guy. Finally. He is the CEO of Dunder Mifflin.
嗯，他们没注意到。他们受到了洛瑞的迎接，她要带迈克尔去休息室。洛瑞由艾米·凯尔·彼得森扮演。当迈克尔到达休息室时，他终于被介绍给了艾伦·布兰德。是的。我们要见到这个艾伦了。终于。他是邓德·米夫林的首席执行官。
He was played by Alan Fudge. In his 37-year career, Alan Fudge appeared on so many television series and in so many films. He had recurring roles on 7th Heaven, Murder She Wrote, LA Law, Matlock, and Colombo. You know, I've been loving my re-watch of Colombo. Oh, love Colombo, yeah. And the office was Alan's final on-screen acting job. He sadly passed away shortly after filming this episode. But we were so fortunate to have him.
他由艾伦·福吉扮演。在他37年的职业生涯中，艾伦·福吉出演了许多电视剧和电影。他在《第七天堂》、《女作家与谋杀案》、《洛杉矶法律》、《马特洛克》和《神探可伦坡》中都有常驻角色。你知道，我一直很喜欢重温《神探可伦坡》。哦，喜欢可伦坡，是的。而《办公室》是艾伦最后一部银幕表演作品。他在拍摄完这一集后不久就遗憾地去世了。但我们很幸运能拥有他。
He's great. Michael also gets introduced to congressman Chris O'Keefe. He bows when he meets him. Yeah. He says, you're eminence. And Chris O'Keefe was played by Chris Ellis. So there are lines forming in this big room that they've rented for this meeting. And Dwight is determined to get to the front of the line.
他很棒。迈克尔还被介绍给了国会议员克里斯·奥基夫。他见到他时鞠了一躬。是的。他说，您的尊贵。而克里斯·奥基夫由克里斯·埃利斯扮演。所以他们为这次会议租的大房间里排起了长队。德怀特决心要排到队伍的最前面。
Yeah. He wants to give Michael a softball question. Early, because then he's got to go to the garment district to grab a crate of his shirts. He has a shirt guy. He does. Now we have figured out where Dwight gets all of the short-sleeve mustard shirts. He has a guy. Well, I guess there were some other things that Dwight might do with his extra time.
是的。他想给迈克尔提一个简单的问题。早点提，因为他之后得去服装区拿一箱他的衬衫。他有专门的衬衫供应商。他确实有。现在我们弄清楚了德怀特所有的短袖芥末色衬衫是从哪里来的了。他有门路。嗯，我想德怀特在空闲时间可能还会做一些其他事情。
They were in our must-shoot candy bag for this episode. Oh, I love a candy bag. What was in there? So guys, these are the alternates that we would shoot for every episode. A must-shoot meant we had to get them. So here are two other things Dwight was going to do with his time. He says, I was hoping to lob Michael his softball question early. Then I was going to sneak away to the New York Public Library and see about this ghost thing for myself.
它们在我们这一集的必拍糖果袋里。哦，我喜欢糖果袋。里面有什么？伙计们，这些是我们为每一集拍摄的备选方案。必拍意味着我们必须拍到它们。所以这是德怀特会利用时间做的另外两件事。他说，我本来希望能早点向迈克尔抛出那个简单的问题。然后我打算溜到纽约公共图书馆，亲自去看看那个鬼魂的事情。
That's like a ghostbusters reference. Right, right. And then the other one was, then I was going to swing down to the diamond district and see what these are worth. And then it says Dwight holds out a black felt cloth with a bunch of small diamonds in it. So either shirts, ghost hunting, or getting some diamonds appraised. I love the shirt one. I love that we finally find out where he gets all of those mustard shirts. I agree.
那就像是《捉鬼敢死队》的梗。对，对。然后另一个是，然后我打算去钻石区看看这些值多少钱。然后上面写着德怀特拿出一块黑色天鹅绒布，里面有一堆小钻石。所以要么是衬衫，要么是捉鬼，要么是去鉴定钻石。我喜欢衬衫那个。我喜欢我们终于发现他从哪里弄到所有那些芥末色衬衫了。我同意。
Well, there's some fun stuff in the deleted scenes of Dwight in this line. You know, Jenna, he becomes classic Dwight. He has rules for his line. Oh, yeah. I mean, when the woman in line asks Dwight if she'll save his place so she can go to the bathroom, he says, no. And then, lady, there was a couplet of dialogue that I love where she says it'll just be a second. And then he says, if onlys and justs were candy and nuts, then every day would be earned to dunk fest. I did a deep dive on earned to dunk fest.
嗯，德怀特在这一排队场景的删减片段里有一些有趣的东西。你知道，珍娜，他变成了经典的德怀特。他为他的队伍制定了规则。哦，是的。我的意思是，当排队的女人问德怀特她去上厕所时能不能帮她占位时，他说，不行。然后，女士，有一句我很喜欢的对话，她说只需要一秒钟。然后他说，如果“如果”和“只要”是糖果和坚果，那每一天都会是“Erntedankfest”（德国丰收节）。我深入研究了一下“Erntedankfest”。
What is that? What is earned to dunk fest? Well, it's German, and it translates as give thanks for the harvest festival. And it's a real thing. It is very similar to America's Thanksgiving, just in that it is time to give thanks and appreciation for that year's harvest. It is traditionally celebrated on the first Sunday that falls after September 29th. And it is traditionally celebrated with a church service by the Catholic and Protestant churches. And then following that, there are parades and a feast.
那是什么？什么是“Erntedankfest”？嗯，它是德语，翻译过来就是“为丰收节感恩”。这是一个真实存在的东西。它和美国的感恩节非常相似，都是为了对当年的丰收表示感谢和赞赏。它传统上在9月29日之后的第一个星期日庆祝。传统上，天主教会和新教教会会举行礼拜仪式。在那之后，会有游行和盛宴。
Now, there is no one meal that served, but you'll usually find like a large chicken or a rooster, I guess, or a fattened hen that is served with root vegetables and bread. You eat rooster? I guess for earned to dunk fest, you can eat a rooster. You can. Okay, if you want. Well, I brought this up to Justin Spitzer. Earned to dunk fest?
现在，没有哪一种特定的食物是必须供应的，但你通常会发现像是一只大鸡或公鸡，我想，或者是一只肥母鸡，配上根茎类蔬菜和面包。你吃公鸡？我想对于“Erntedankfest”，你可以吃公鸡。你可以。好吧，如果你想的话。嗯，我把这个提给了贾斯汀·斯皮策。“Erntedankfest”？
Yeah. And I said, I just loved that line. And he wrote back and said, well, Jenna, there's sort of a code where writers aren't supposed to take credit for like certain moments in a script. But it was his. And I just write it. And it's really funny to me. So thank you for appreciating it. It was really funny. Well, listen, we got a little ahead of ourselves.
是的。我说，我太喜欢那句台词了。他回信说，嗯，珍娜，编剧界有一种不成文的规定，不应该为剧本中的某些时刻邀功。但那是他的。我只是把它写下来。对我来说这真的很有趣。所以谢谢你的欣赏。这真的很有趣。好吧，听着，我们有点超前了。
We should back up because we have to see Oscar and Andy enter this shareholder meeting now. Well, let's take a break. And when we come back, Oscar is furious and Andy is really encouraging him to say something. Music All right, we're back. And Oscar and Andy are making their way down the aisle. Oscar is incensed at the money that was spent on this event. Oscar actually has some really good ideas.
我们应该往回退一点，因为我们现在得看奥斯卡和安迪进入这个股东大会。嗯，我们休息一下。回来后，奥斯卡非常愤怒，安迪一直在鼓励他说点什么。音乐 好了，我们回来了。奥斯卡和安迪正沿着过道走。奥斯卡对这次活动花费的钱感到愤怒。奥斯卡其实有一些非常好的想法。
I know. And Andy says, you know, you should say something. You should go to the bike. I spotted something in this scene. What? At eight minutes, 15 seconds, I spotted a mic hide. A mic hide? Do you remember the way that they would hide the microphones inside the knot of the men's ties?
我知道。安迪说，你知道，你应该说点什么。你应该去麦克风那里。我在这个场景里发现了一个东西。什么？在8分15秒，我发现了一个麦克风隐藏点。麦克风隐藏点？你还记得他们把麦克风藏在男士领带结里的方式吗？
Oh, yeah. They would put this squishy thing around the microphone. It kind of looks like an earplug with a hole in the middle. They would stick the mic in that and then they would put that whole thing into the knot of the tie. And you can only see it if you know to look for it. But I think I could see it in Oscar's tie as he's walking down the aisle. Well, now you know about the mic hide and the tie. It'll be all that you look for, guys.
哦，是的。他们会把这个软绵绵的东西放在麦克风周围。它看起来有点像中间有孔的耳塞。他们会把麦克风插进去，然后把整个东西塞进领带结里。只有你知道去观察才能看到它。但我认为我在奥斯卡走过过道时，能看到他领带里的那个东西。好吧，现在你知道了麦克风隐藏点和领带的事了。伙计们，这会成为你们唯一会去寻找的东西。
I know. You're welcome. Back in the office, we have a little bit of what I'm calling sass in the break room. Jim's having problems. I guess he asked Ryan to import all of their contacts into Outlook. But Ryan is like, isn't the company going under? Yeah. I mean, shouldn't we wait to find out?
我知道。不客气。回到办公室，我们有一点我称之为休息室里的“傲慢”。吉姆遇到了麻烦。我想他让瑞安把他们所有的联系人导入Outlook。但瑞安却说，公司不是要倒闭了吗？是的。我的意思是，我们不应该等一等再看吗？
Like, why do all this work if the company's going under? I mean, he kind of has a point, but he's also being a slacker. Yeah, I do see his point, though. I know. It feels like busy work. Yeah. Honestly, Jim, it feels like busy work. Five minutes, 48 seconds, we got a coffee mug call back.
比如，如果公司要倒闭了，为什么要做这些工作？我的意思是，他有点道理，但他也在偷懒。是的，我确实明白他的意思。我知道。这感觉像是无用功。是的。老实说，吉姆，这感觉像是无用功。5分48秒，我们有一个咖啡杯的回顾。
What is it? Meredith is drinking out of her America's Got Talent Coffee Mug from Customer Survey. The problems for Jim are not going to get any easier. Phyllis is going to come back from her lunch, a long lunch. Two hour lunch. I mean, we know what Bob and Phyllis do in the bathroom at lunch. Oh, Lord, remember? I hadn't even gone there.
是什么？梅雷迪思正在用她从“客户调查”那一集里得到的“美国达人”咖啡杯喝水。吉姆的麻烦不会变得更容易。菲利斯要从午餐回来了，一个漫长的午餐。两小时的午餐。我的意思是，我们知道鲍勃和菲利斯在午餐时在浴室里做什么。哦，天哪，还记得吗？我甚至都没往那方面想。
Yeah. I mean, this was a long lunch. I think we know what they were up to. She says she's a little tipsy, which she just admits that to her boss, Jim. Jim's like, why are you saying this to me? But Jenna, I have a question for you. What is it? How do you say the word fire?
是的。我的意思是，这是一个漫长的午餐。我想我们知道他们在干什么。她说她有点醉了，她就这样向她的老板吉姆承认了。吉姆说，你为什么要跟我说这些？但珍娜，我有一个问题要问你。是什么？你怎么读“fire”（火/解雇）这个词？
Fire. Fire. Yeah. Sam. Fire. Cassie. Fire. Fire.
Fire。Fire。是的。萨姆。Fire。凯西。Fire。Fire。
Because listen to how Phyllis says it. I thought I could hear a little bit of St. Louis in that fire. Hey Phyllis, are you just getting back from lunch now? Mmm, Bob took me to Capellos. We got a little tipsy. Okay. Shouldn't be telling me that stuff and also shouldn't be taking two hour lunches without telling me.
因为听听菲利斯是怎么说的。我想我能在那声“fire”里听到一点圣路易斯的口音。嘿，菲利斯，你现在才从午餐回来吗？嗯，鲍勃带我去了Capellos。我们喝得有点醉了。好的。你不应该告诉我这些，也不应该在没告诉我的情况下吃两小时的午餐。
Oh, it's okay. Michael doesn't really care about these things. I care about them. And I'm just as much of a boss as Michael. What's so funny? I'm a co-manager. That doesn't make you a boss. It's not like you can fire people or anything.
哦，没关系。迈克尔并不真正在意这些事情。我在意。而且我和迈克尔一样都是老板。有什么好笑的？我是联合经理。那并不意味着你是老板。又不是说你能解雇人什么的。
What? Who? How did you? Who told you this? We can't say. Far. Far people or anything. Far people.
什么？谁？你怎么？谁告诉你的？我们不能说。“Far”（解雇的方言发音）人什么的。“Far”人。
Far. You know what I need to do is ask my mom and dad to say far. Yes. To see what they say. Because she says far to far. Right. Far. I think maybe.
“Far”。你知道我需要做的是让我爸妈说“far”。是的。看看他们怎么说。因为她说“far”来“far”人。对。“Far”。我想也许。
Mmm-hmm. Accent catch. Way to go. You're welcome. St. Louis. Limousine. Far. Far.
嗯哼。口音捕捉。干得好。不客气。圣路易斯。豪华轿车。“Far”。“Far”。
Well, by the way, this sets off a whole thing. Can Jim far people or not? Everyone seems to think he can't. Even Pam for a second. Yes. She forgot that she has to support Jim no matter what. That was a close one, she says. Back at the fancy shareholder meeting.
嗯，顺便说一句，这引发了一连串的事情。吉姆到底能不能“far”（解雇）人？每个人似乎都认为他不能。连帕姆有一瞬间也这么想。是的。她忘了无论如何她都必须支持吉姆。她说，那真是千钧一发。回到豪华的股东大会。
It's show time for Michael. Mmm-hmm. He's going to be introduced. Do his wave. He does. And he does do the wave. He doesn't twirl. Thank goodness.
迈克尔的表演时间到了。嗯哼。他要被介绍了。做他的招牌挥手动作。他做了。他确实做了那个挥手动作。他没有转圈。谢天谢地。
Yeah. It's still a bit awkward. And that's it. Then he just sits down. In the audience though. And he will not stop encouraging Oscar to stand up and go to the microphone and say what's what. Yeah.
是的。还是有点尴尬。就是这样。然后他就坐下了。不过在观众席里。他不停地鼓励奥斯卡站起来走到麦克风前，把事情说清楚。是的。
Andy says he's, you know, the guy that rallies other people to rebel. He once organized a walkout over standardized testing and got over 500 students to skip the SATs. Mmm-hmm. Andy chickened out and he took them anyway. He scored a 12-20. Yeah. He feels very lack-remose about it.
安迪说他，你知道，是那种号召别人反抗的人。他曾经组织过一次针对标准化考试的罢考，让500多名学生跳过了SAT考试。嗯哼。安迪临阵脱逃了，他还是去参加了。他考了1220分。是的。他对此感到非常“lack-remose”（忧伤）。
Mmm-hmm. Which means tearful or given to weeping. I looked it up too. So did I. I mean, I was like, I feel like I should figure out what that means. Yeah. Well, he got a 12-20 on his SATs. Mmm-hmm.
嗯哼。意思是泪流满面或容易哭泣。我也查了。我也查了。我的意思是，我当时想，我觉得我应该弄清楚那是什么意思。是的。嗯，他在SAT考试中得了1220分。嗯哼。
This led me to a many deep dive. Her, a website called Prep Scholar who did a survey in 2019. The SAT score range is 400 to 1600 for your total score. One section scores math while the other is a combined reading and writing. As you would expect the higher your score, the better you did compared to the other test takers. I wanted to know where did Andy rank. Okay.
这引导我进行了一次深入研究。一个叫Prep Scholar的网站在2019年做了一项调查。SAT总分范围是400到1600分。一部分是数学，另一部分是阅读和写作的综合。正如你所料，你的分数越高，你比其他考生做得就越好。我想知道安迪排在什么位置。好的。
I thought he sounded like he did pretty good. I did too. So he would have been in the 74th percentile. No. Very well. I know. I did not take the SAT. No.
我觉得他听起来考得还不错。我也这么觉得。所以他应该在第74百分位。不。非常好。我知道。我没参加过SAT。不。
I scheduled it. But my ACT was before my SAT. Mmm-hmm. And I took my ACT and I scored high enough to get into my College of Choice. So I just didn't take the SAT. I was like, wait, can I, can I get in with my ACT score? And they were like, yeah. I was like, cool.
我预约了。但我的ACT考试在SAT之前。嗯哼。我参加了ACT考试，分数高到足以进入我选择的大学。所以我没参加SAT。我当时想，等等，我能用我的ACT分数进去吗？他们说，可以。我说，酷。
I took both. And you know, now they're moving it to a digital online version, but I did the old fashioned paper and pencil. Me too. And a big auditorium where I had to sit every other row. Yeah. Super spaced apart. Exactly.
我两个都参加了。你知道，现在他们正在转向数字在线版本，但我做的是老式的纸笔考试。我也是。在一个大礼堂里，我必须隔一行坐一个。是的。间隔很大。完全正确。
Yeah. I took both of them. ACT, SAT. After college, my college had this, um, they had this standardized test that you had to take to test out of college. You didn't have to pass it or get any certain score to leave the school, but they just wanted it like for their records, I think, just to show how people would score on tests after attending their school.
是的。我两个都参加了。ACT，SAT。大学毕业后，我的大学有这个，嗯，他们有一个标准化考试，你必须参加才能从大学毕业。你不需要通过它或获得任何特定的分数才能离开学校，但他们只是想要它作为记录，我想，只是为了展示人们在就读学校后在考试中会得多少分。
Right. Yeah. And I was like bitter about it. It was like a Saturday. I had to get up really early. And it was standardized weirdly. It was on a computer. It was all multiple choice.
对。是的。我当时对此很反感。那是一个星期六。我必须起得很早。而且它很奇怪地标准化了。它是在电脑上进行的。全是多项选择题。
And I started taking the test and it was going to be one of those two to three hour tests. And at a certain point, guess what? You left. Every answer was C. I just went C, C, C, C, C. I didn't do that bad on it. Oh my gosh. You just played the odds of hitting C over and over. I did. So I'm sorry to my university that I actually really loved that I just found it in on that
我开始参加考试，这本来会是那种两到三个小时的考试之一。在某个时刻，你猜怎么着？你离开了。每个答案都是C。我只是选了C，C，C，C，C。我考得没那么差。天哪。你只是利用了反复选C的概率。我确实这么做了。所以我很抱歉我的大学，我其实真的很喜欢它，但我只是在那次考试中敷衍了事，因为我不想参加。所以这就是我做的。
test, but I didn't want to take it. So that's why I did. Well, that's what happened. So they maybe didn't look so good on their stats that year. It wasn't bad though, I'll say. Don't make me take a test to try to make you look good. That's right. That's not my job.
好吧，事情就是这样。所以他们那一年的统计数据可能看起来不太好。不过我得说，并不坏。别让我参加考试来让你看起来不错。没错。那不是我的工作。
My job was to pay you money and get an education. And then we just, we part ways. Well, I think that joke only works if Andy does well on the test. After he talked everybody else out of taking it. That's a good button for the joke that he was in the 74th percentile. Right. But he regrets it. He regrets taking it.
我的工作是付钱给你并接受教育。然后我们就分道扬镳了。嗯，我觉得那个笑话只有在安迪考试考得好的情况下才成立。在他劝说其他人不要参加之后。对于他处于第74百分位这个笑话来说，这是一个很好的结尾。对。但他后悔了。他后悔参加了。
He does. The crowd is taken to the mic and they're angry and they're saying that the board of Denver Mifflin are criminals. And Michael is going to defend the company. He's going to do what Michael does best and pretty much burn it to the ground. He is going to share about how great Dunder Mifflin is. They sent him a limo and all this free food. Yes.
他确实后悔。人群走到麦克风前，他们很愤怒，说邓德·米夫林的董事会是罪犯。迈克尔要为公司辩护。他要去做迈克尔最擅长的事情，几乎把它彻底搞砸。他要分享邓德·米夫林有多棒。他们送了他一辆豪华轿车和所有这些免费食物。是的。
Can you believe it? The crowd gets even angrier like to the point where they're running these guys off the stage. So Michael promises that they're going to take a break, but they're going to come back from their break. This is my favorite thing with a 45-day, 45-point plan to get the company back on track. Now the crowd goes wild. Michael's got him in the palm of his hand. And he doesn't stop there.
你敢相信吗？人群变得更加愤怒，以至于他们要把这些人赶下台。所以迈克尔承诺他们会休息一下，但他们休息后会回来。这是我最喜欢的事情，有一个45天、45点的计划让公司重回正轨。现在人群疯狂了。迈克尔把他们玩弄于股掌之间。而且他并没有就此停止。
He says, limo lady, this is the woman who was angry about the limo, we're going carbon neutral. Everyone cheers and they're like, get him off the stage, but he like runs back for an encore spin. Yeah. He got the spin in. He got the twirl and the wave, all of it. You know, that carbon neutral line, that was another little nod to green week.
他说，豪华轿车女士，这就是那个对豪华轿车感到愤怒的女人，我们要实现碳中和。每个人都欢呼，他们就像是，把他赶下台，但他又跑回来做了一个安可旋转。是的。他完成了旋转。他完成了旋转和挥手，所有的一切。你知道，那句碳中和的台词，是向“绿色周”致敬的另一个小细节。
But man, I love a 45-day, 45-point plan to get things done. It made me want to make one for my own life just to make it. Here's the part I love. One point per day. We get the 45 points and we are back in business. Exactly. You just get one point a day. Well, then when he goes up to the, up to the lake holding room and those guys are freaking
但是伙计，我喜欢45天、45点的计划来完成事情。它让我想要为我自己的生活制定一个，只是为了制定它。这是我喜欢的部分。每天一点。我们得到45点，我们就恢复营业了。完全正确。你每天只需要得到一点。嗯，然后当他走到湖边的休息室，那些家伙吓坏了。
out, they're like, Michael, what have you done? He's like, listen, get me a pen of paper. The only answer here is to do what I said. So day 45, company saved. What's day 44? Yeah. He's going to work backwards. It's so amazing.
他们说，迈克尔，你做了什么？他说，听着，给我一支笔和一张纸。这里唯一的答案就是做我说的。所以第45天，公司得救了。第44天是什么？是的。他要倒着工作。太神奇了。
And he's like, we got 15 minutes. Let's do this. Well, I would say up in the lounge at 15 minutes, 44 seconds, I have a Fiji water catch. I knew you would and at 15 minutes, 51 seconds, I got a Gouda catch. What's a Gouda catch? It's an enormous plate of Gouda. There's so much Gouda. What if there is?
他说，我们还有15分钟。让我们开始吧。嗯，我会说在15分44秒的休息室里，我有一个斐济水捕捉。我就知道你会有的，在15分51秒，我有一个高达奶酪捕捉。什么是高达奶酪捕捉？那是一大盘高达奶酪。有太多的高达奶酪了。如果真的有呢？
I couldn't get over it. I had to take a picture of the screen. I did not get the Gouda catch, but at 17 minutes, I have a New York Times catch. It's sitting out on the table. I thought that was a very nice detail from Phil Shea. Well, it's 1709. I've got a fabulous plant catch. What?
我无法释怀。我不得不拍了一张屏幕照片。我没有得到高达奶酪捕捉，但在17分钟，我有一个《纽约时报》捕捉。它放在桌子上。我觉得那是菲尔·谢的一个非常好的细节。嗯，现在是17分09秒。我有一个绝妙的植物捕捉。什么？
There are so many great plants in the scene. Okay. I just have to say, I love that I spotted water and a newspaper and you spotted some cheese and plants. That is all you need to know about us. That is everything. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh.
这个场景里有很多很棒的植物。好的。我不得不说，我喜欢我发现了水和报纸，而你发现了一些奶酪和植物。这就是你需要知道的关于我们的一切。这就是全部。天哪。天哪。
Well, Michael has a plan. He's going to call Oscar. Oscar has all these great ideas. He's an accountant. He's going to get him up there to talk to everybody. This is not a bad idea. I know, but Oscar completely chokes. He's worried he's going to get fired if he tells the truth to these big bosses.
嗯，迈克尔有一个计划。他要给奥斯卡打电话。奥斯卡有很多很棒的想法。他是个会计。他要让他上去和大家谈谈。这不是个坏主意。我知道，但奥斯卡完全卡壳了。他担心如果他告诉这些大老板真相，他会被解雇。
Yeah. Well, this really sets off the room. The congressman calls Michael a moron and Michael goes, I'm not a moron. Then after time, my branch leads in sales. I have personally won over 17 Dundee Awards, which guys are awards he basically gives himself. Yeah. Oh. Well, then congressman O'Keeffe says he's taken back the limo.
是的。嗯，这真的让房间里的人炸开了锅。国会议员称迈克尔是白痴，迈克尔说，我不是白痴。然后，我的分部在销售方面领先。我个人赢得了超过17个邓迪奖，伙计们，这些奖项基本上是他自己颁给自己的。是的。哦。嗯，然后国会议员奥基夫说他要收回豪华轿车。
You guys don't get to ride the limo back to Scranton. Michael Hall's ass out of there. He gets the guys who's like, let's go, let's go. Load it up. Well, they jump into the limo. They yell at the driver to drive. They've got booze. They're celebrating.
你们不能坐豪华轿车回斯克兰顿了。迈克尔把他们拉走了。他带着那些家伙说，走吧，走吧。装车。嗯，他们跳进豪华轿车。他们对司机大喊开车。他们有酒。他们在庆祝。
Their hands go up out of the sunroof. It's very exciting. It's a big party. Few background catches here and some tidbits from Randy at 20 minutes, eight seconds at the limo loading area. Randy said they rented five additional limos for the day to make it appear that the Dundermifflin corporate people had truly been overdoing it. Right?
他们的手从天窗伸出来。非常令人兴奋。这是一个大型派对。这里有一些背景捕捉和兰迪提供的一些小知识，在20分08秒的豪华轿车装载区。兰迪说他们当天额外租了五辆豪华轿车，让邓德·米夫林公司的人看起来确实做得太过分了。对吧？
I like that. 20 minutes, 22 seconds per Randy. Can you see the hands outside the limo from the outside shot? Yes. The cast had already been released for the day, so those hands are Randy's, our stand-in Steven Socks, our PA Greg Ubaraga, and our PA Chuck Canzeroni. No way. I love that.
我喜欢那个。根据兰迪的说法，20分22秒。你能从外面的镜头看到豪华轿车外面的手吗？是的。演员们当天已经收工了，所以那些手是兰迪的、我们的替身史蒂文·索克斯、我们的制片助理格雷格·乌巴拉加和我们的制片助理查克·坎泽罗尼的。没门。我喜欢那个。
Yeah, and they all put on dress like suit jackets so they could match when their hands went out. Well, when the limo's driving down the street right after that shot, you see the Dundermifflin stock ticker go by on a building and you can see that it's dropping. The arrow, the down arrow. Yeah. Well, I guess creating this very small moment of this ticker on the side of the building took a lot of effort.
是的，他们都穿上了西装外套，这样当他们的手伸出来时就能匹配。嗯，当豪华轿车在那之后行驶在街上时，你看到邓德·米夫林的股票代码在建筑物上经过，你可以看到它在下跌。那个箭头，向下箭头。是的。嗯，我想创造这个建筑物侧面代码的非常小的时刻花了很多精力。
I was curious about it because I don't recall us having things like that in downtown LA, but they're very popular in New York. They wrap around like electronic billboard. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, we totally faked it. That is a fakey ticker. Like the sign doesn't even exist on the building.
我对此很好奇，因为我不记得我们在洛杉矶市中心有这样的东西，但它们在纽约非常受欢迎。它们像电子广告牌一样环绕。是的。是的。我的意思是，我们完全是伪造的。那是一个伪造的代码。就像那个标志甚至不存在于建筑物上一样。
Yes. Wow. He said they started by finding real buildings in New York that had stock tickers, and then they tried to find a building in downtown LA that kind of matched it. So they settled on the Brooks Brothers building. Just to be clear, there is no ticker on the side of this building. So our graphics designer, Henry Sane, created the fake ticker and then Stargate International, which was our go-to CGI company, they put it on the building and made it look 3D.
是的。哇。他说他们首先在纽约找到了有股票代码的真实建筑物，然后他们试图在洛杉矶市中心找到一个与之匹配的建筑物。所以他们选择了布鲁克斯兄弟大楼。需要明确的是，这座建筑物的侧面没有代码。所以我们的图形设计师亨利·塞恩制作了伪造的代码，然后我们的首选CGI公司Stargate International把它放在建筑物上，让它看起来是3D的。
Fakey ticker. Well done, fakey ticker. Well that finishes out the fellas at the shareholder meeting. Back in Scranton, here we are. We're at that scene that we started with in mom detectives. 15 minutes, 32 seconds, count them, four mysterious gift bags on Kelly's desk. Ryan is continuing to be defiant, and Jim finally has the answer. Yeah.
伪造代码。干得好，伪造代码。嗯，这结束了股东大会上的伙计们。回到斯克兰顿，我们到了。我们回到了我们在“妈妈侦探”中开始的那个场景。15分32秒，数一数，凯利的桌子上有四个神秘的礼品袋。瑞安继续反抗，吉姆终于有了答案。是的。
He's going to give him a new office. And that office is the closet off the kitchen. The old supply closet. I remember when they built that closet. I do too. I do too. And it really was very tiny. It was.
他要给他一个新的办公室。那个办公室是厨房旁边的壁橱。旧的供应壁橱。我记得他们建造那个壁橱的时候。我也记得。我也记得。它确实非常小。它确实是。
When you would see BJ as Ryan in there, like at his little desk, it was really funny looking. And it really was very enclosed, like when you shut the door, it was pitch dark. Yes, it was. This episode has a tag at the end that sort of like takes us back in time. We would do this sometimes. We see Dwight finally getting his turn at the microphone, and instead of talking about Dunder Mifflin, he's going to give a speech about how to improve the line situation. We just used to like to do this.
当你看到BJ饰演的瑞安在里面时，比如在他那张小桌子旁，看起来真的很滑稽。而且它确实非常封闭，当你关上门时，里面漆黑一片。是的，确实是。这一集在结尾有一个标签，有点像把我们带回了过去。我们有时会这样做。我们看到德怀特终于轮到他使用麦克风了，他没有谈论邓德·米夫林，而是要发表关于如何改善排队情况的演讲。我们只是过去喜欢这样做。
If there was a bit, if there was a joke that didn't make it into an episode, sometimes we would use it as a tag, and that's what happened here. We got a lot of mail of people saying, wait a second, did Dwight go back to the hotel because he was in the limo? No. This was sort of like a flashback kind of tag. Yes, exactly. It was like sort of out of sequence.
如果有一个片段，如果有一个笑话没有进入某一集，有时我们会把它用作标签，这就是这里发生的事情。我们收到了很多邮件，人们说，等一下，德怀特回酒店了吗，因为他在豪华轿车里？不。这有点像倒叙式的标签。是的，完全正确。它有点像是不按顺序的。
Yes. Well, that was Shareholder Meeting. I hope you guys enjoyed it, Jen. I hope you enjoyed your cookies and your flowers. I did. I have had a wonderful birthday, I want to say. It's been stretched out in our family instead of doing gifts as much. Sometimes we do experiences.
是的。嗯，那就是“股东大会”。希望你们喜欢，珍。希望你喜欢你的饼干和花。我喜欢。我想说，我度过了一个美好的生日。在我们家里，它被拉长了，而不是像以前那样送礼物。有时我们做体验。
So like my son took me to my first Lakers game. So fun. I know. And I got to see that game where LeBron James like scored all the like gazillion points. That sounds like LeBron. I know. Listen to me, like my first basketball game. You guys, LeBron James scored a gazillion points.
比如我儿子带我去了我的第一场湖人队比赛。太有趣了。我知道。我看到了勒布朗·詹姆斯得了那几亿分的那场比赛。听起来很像勒布朗。我知道。听我说，就像我第一次看篮球比赛一样。伙计们，勒布朗·詹姆斯得了几亿分。
He's really good. He's a very good basketball player. Yes, he is. When I was there, it was funny because I turned to my husband and I said, these Laker girls are very good dancers. It's like truly like a person being there for the first time. But I loved it. And then my daughter arranged for me to have manicure pedicure with her.
他真的很棒。他是一个非常好的篮球运动员。是的，他是。我在那里的时候，很有趣，因为我转向我丈夫说，这些湖人女孩是很好的舞者。就像一个第一次去那里的人。但我喜欢它。然后我女儿安排我和她一起做美甲和足疗。
Aw. So cute. And then you guys, my husband, Lee, I love you so much. He converted the little room off our garage into an exercise room for me. The little storage room? Yes. Are you going to get your work out on that? I am.
噢。太可爱了。然后你们，我丈夫，李，我太爱你了。他把我们车库旁边的小房间改成了我的健身房。那个小储藏室？是的。你要在那上面锻炼吗？我要。
I told him that I've been wanting to have this goal of getting back into shape, kind of like just moving my muscles a little bit more. I took a long time off for the pandemic. Yes. Yeah. I think a lot of us did. We all did. Well, we had shoved our Peloton into this little kind of closet room and it was mostly
我告诉他，我一直想有一个恢复身材的目标，就像只是多活动一下我的肌肉。我在疫情期间休息了很长时间。是的。是的。我想我们很多人都这样。我们都这样。嗯，我们把我们的Peloton塞进了这个小壁橱房间里，它大部分时间是
used for storage. And he cleaned it all out and he put down like the little like foam floor. Oh, wow. Yeah, and he got me some kettle bells and all this stuff. I made him a list. He said, what would be, you know, the stuff you'd want in this little room. And so I can take my iPad in there and watch my workout videos and I love it. So thank you.
用来存放东西的。他把它清理干净，铺上了像泡沫地板一样的东西。哦，哇。是的，他给我买了一些壶铃和所有这些东西。我给他列了个清单。他说，你想要在这个小房间里放什么东西。所以我可以把我的iPad带进去看我的健身视频，我喜欢它。所以谢谢。
And now I got all this stuff here today, but I had a great birthday and I also got great birthday wishes from people online and through the office ladies post. I mean, I just felt so loved. Well, you are so loved. Thank you, everyone. I know this is going to air long after my birthday, but thank you. I'm now 48. You're a sassy 48.
现在我今天在这里得到了所有这些东西，但我度过了一个很棒的生日，我也从网上和通过“办公室女士”的帖子得到了很棒的生日祝福。我的意思是，我感到被爱。嗯，你被深深地爱着。谢谢大家。我知道这一集会在我生日很久之后播出，但谢谢。我现在48岁了。你是一个时髦的48岁。
You look fabulous. We love you so much, lady. Thank you guys. Thank you. And Mindy, if you're out there listening and you know why there were four gift bags on your desk at 15 minutes, 32 seconds in this episode, let us know. We'd love to hear it. We'd love to know.
你看上去棒极了。我们非常爱你，女士。谢谢你们。谢谢。还有明迪，如果你在听，并且你知道为什么在这一集的15分32秒你的桌子上有四个礼品袋，请告诉我们。我们很想听听。我们很想知道。
We're going to wrap up with Mindy singing because it's fantastic. I love that idea. We will see you next week. You're the male pre-Madonna, but I can't help but want you. I'm an independent diva, but I still kind of need you. Together we're apart. It's tearing up my heart. I'm an hell and a bonacla.
我们要以明迪的歌声结束，因为它太棒了。我喜欢那个主意。我们下周见。你是男版麦当娜，但我忍不住想要你。我是个独立的歌后，但我还是有点需要你。我们在一起却又分开。这让我的心碎了。我是个……
You're the male pre-Madonna. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
你是男版麦当娜。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是凯西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版本的“办公室女士”，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码：OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。